if you've seen the trailer for the call
you have seen the movie the call if
you're one of the fortunate ones to have
not seen the trailer no I was so sick of
this movie before I saw it so I dragged
myself to the theater and you know what
who's actually pretty damn good I have
never seen a movie with a trailer that
had so many spoilers yet when i watch
the film knowing what was coming that's
what she said I still found it to be a
fun entertaining suspenseful thrill ride
the movie is made for audiences I can
see our critics would hate it mainly
based off his final act because that's
where the film butts up and the closing
scene belongs in another type of movie
but here's the honest truth [ __ ]
loved it I got a total kick out of the
weird ending and plus that's just the
final act there's a whole two thirds
that's really rock solid you know why
because it's a classic Hollywood thrill
ride the audience was cheering it was
great to be a part of the crowd where
there's applause throughout cuz they
really want the main characters to win
you really want Halle Berry to get her
Redemption you really want Abigail
Breslin not to get killed and Michael
Eklund has a serial killer bring
surprisingly good depth to this film and
you really want him to lose you care for
these people's lives it moves in a fun
thriller case there's also some
wonderful cinematography I had a total
blast even though the trailer is loaded
with spoilers it's way better than the
trailer like I said it's just a fun
Hollywood thrill ride and you know what
else I saw Django Unchained again this
week and movies [ __ ] awesome and then
I saw the call and between Jamie Foxx
being a badass and Halle Berry being a
badass black people are just rockin it
this week let me get straight to the
point here all in all i gotta say the
call got it right
you
alright guys thanks for watching the
video you can go ahead and tell me your
points below and if you like the video
go ahead and like the video and if you
want to see an in-depth review of the
call go ahead and watch my show that I
do with my buddy Jerry called reasons to
see where we give your reasons to see
and not to see the coal and last but not
least if you want to get updated every
time a new video is out go ahead and
subscribe to my channel